- So Starbucks came out with
this Smoked Butterscotch Latte,
and everybody on the internet is saying
that it's basically Butterbeer.
So we're gonna try it and
figure out if that's true.
(whoosh)
(spooky music)
- I'm not a fan of Harry Potter.
- I love everything Harry Potter!
- I am a Potterhead.
- Harry Potter is literally life.
- If one more person or
book wants to convince me
that the "chosen one"
is some basic white guy,
I'm gonna slap them across the face.
(lightning snap)
(playful music)
- Butterbeer is a beer from
Hogwarts, I'm assuming.
- It's like butterscotch
and a little bit of heaven.
- I have tried the actual Butterbeer
at the Wizard World of Harry Potter.
- Is Butterbeer like a Harry Potter thing?
I so don't know what Butterbeer is.
What is it?
- Sweet Jesus.
- This is gonna change your life.
You're gonna read the books after this.
- It looks like something from Starbucks.
- Yeah.
- Cheers.
- Cheers to terribleness.
- Butterbeer and greatness.
- To grossness.
- Childhood.
- And badness.
- Okay, this already doesn't
smell like Butterbeer.
- It's got that, like,
butterscotchy flavor,
so I can see why people would
say it's like Butterbeer.
- This is nothing like the
Butterbeer that I tried
at Harry Potter World.
- It just tastes like butterscotch.
- Okay, so this isn't quite Butterbeer
from the Wizarding World of Harry Potter,
which I think is the closest
that you can get to the book,
but I do like this drink.
- It's like candy, it's great.
- I think this is as
disappointing as Harry Potter,
so it's consistent with the legacy.
- I curse you with my spells.
It's more about just, like,
imposing the fandom onto the drink.
- Yeah, yeah.
(squeaking)